joining me now is former secretary of
state mike pompeo distinguished fellow
at the hudson institute fox news
contributor mr secretary great to see
you i want to jump right in
democrats are so worried are they not
about protecting democracies around the
world you know we all are but when it
comes to what's happening here in the
united states apparently the government
will just use
every
bit of power at its disposal to target
one man who is a likely
a 2024 presidential candidate what are
your what are your thoughts on what
you're hearing tonight
gloria you've got it exactly right
there's there's no rules right this is
just about power
and they asked us to give give them the
benefit of the doubt the talking about
democracy and equal justice under the
law but we've seen it right we saw uh my
predecessor ca jim brennan uh
politicized weaponized the cia
we saw jim comey uh who was my
counterpart at fbi when i was a ci
director at the beginning of my time we
saw him take notes link them to the
press we've watched the justice
department under merrick garland go
after parents as terrorists who are just
trying to make sure their kids got in
school there is no reason to give them
the benefit of the doubt it has not been
remotely equal and what they did in
mar-a-lago that day
runs just square against the central
thesis which is about transparent equal
application of the law in the united
states especially when you do it against
someone who was your former and could
potentially be soon could be again your
political opponent we don't see this in
america this is
not something that should go lightly and
it is bigger than what just happened in
florida last week i mean mr secretary we
had hillary clinton's people destroying
thousands and thousands of emails this
is when donors to the clinton foundation
were trying to get in to talk to mrs
clinton you were secretary of state
imagine if you had done anything
approaching what was going on when she
was secretary of state
i wouldn't even be talking to you right
now they'd probably put you in rikers
island i mean
it's just crazy so that's why there's a
double standard here that you know
national archive didn't have any problem
with that apparently
the goodness laura you know i was you
don't forget i was in the middle of that
i was on the benghazi committee with
trey gowdy and jim jordan we were
working to try and get access to her
emails and her server which everyone
admits has high level classified
information we didn't we didn't raid her
home we didn't send the justice
department we tried to work through the
problem set in the tradition of america
they have violated these most basic
understandings uh and your points well
taken had had my wife given speeches for
five hundred thousand dollars to throw
all across the world to foreign
governments while i was serving
secretary of state i'd have an orange
jumpsuit and a prisoner number
and i you know looking at you and your
colors tonight orange is not your color
mike it's not that's
definitely about you're more of a darker
hued per person all right i know you're
interviewed by the january 6 commission
what can you share
about your lovely time with them
uh you know they were they were chasing
witches right this was uh this was a far
field wandering interview i spoke the
truth to them i can't tell you the
details laura they were looking for
discussions about the 25th amendment
discussions that i never seriously
undertook with any of my counterparts
they were they were looking to build a
storyline the conclusion of which was
already written
um your reaction to what mike pence said
up in new hampshire about how people
you know shouldn't criticize the be
careful about criticizing the fbi
because that's criticizing the rank and
file you know i i like mike pence very
much he's an old friend going back 20
plus years but i was a little surprised
by that your reaction to what he said
uh we all have friends i've got two
folks who used to work on my
congressional staff who are now young
kick butt fbi agents all across america
good people hard-working folks that care
about america but when you have a
politicized leadership when you have
mccabe lying losing his job and then now
being the spokesperson on cnn
when you see the fbi engaged in this
kind of activity
it's so deeply troubling that one can
easily
easily take on the fbi leadership
without maligning in any way those folks
are out there trying to keep our streets
safe and keep us safe from crime all
across the country um what were you
doing the night that liz cheney
lost the
lost the race in wyoming now are you
surprised by that in any way shape or
form i mean obviously
you were friendly with the cheneys as
many of us were but that is the end of
that era is it not
yeah i think it is it's from it's from a
time gone by in the sense of um she
spent her entire time representing the
people of wyoming going after a single
individual instead of representing the
people of wyoming and they responded
they responded pretty clearly and pretty
sharply and pretty dramatically
mr secretary it's great to see you
tonight thank you so much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else